when i was a tottenham and i played um
it was a cup game against northampton
okay it was a little a little bit
low and there's a break and i remember
going to the back of the goal
and taking a drink and like the whole
back stand there just completely monkey
chance wow
[Music]
[Music]
tell us about an experience of racism
you've had
in the game i'm i'm heavily involved in
a
grassroots scene at the moment and
there's a lot of black
managers coaches you know volunteers
and you know they're doing their
coaching badges and they do tell me that
they are struggling
i'm part of a bme i'm black ethnic
minority i'm one of them
um so you know when i see it does happen
to them it does hurt me it does affect
me
i remember uh i was playing for um
uh tottenham on a friendly uh i think he
was playing lazio
okay on a friendly and i was the first
time i heard
one of the players say the n-word to me
well platform we did
you know and the worst one i've had is
when i was a tottenham and i
played um it was a cup game against
northampton
it was a little bit low and there's a
break and i remember going
to the back of the goal and taking a
drink and like the whole
back stand there just completely monkey
chance
wow how do you feel in that moment i
felt like
what is this was there any action taken
no
i'm sure there's worse things that
happened to human beings
but for me as a sports man you know
that's
unacceptable it's not sport anymore
exactly when you start saying those kind
of things it's not sport
yeah how did you deal with it was there
anyone you spoke to
um being you know such a young person at
a time
no no one backed me up like back in the
days that was normal yeah
you know that's 20 odd years ago so
no one said anything we won the game
next week you move on
does the media portray black players
differently to white players
a black player maybe strong is
is stronger than ox is a beast or
whatever and then someone who
may be lighter or white or intelligent
play and things like that
why can't that guy be intelligent as
well when you think about it that seeps
into the consciousness of people
the media are such a powerful tool it's
a powerful tool
and you know a lot of people buy into it
a lot of people
read it and straight away and they think
oh that's the correct thing and that's
the right thing
it's been going on for far too long and
now they're trying to re-correct things
are there fewer opportunities for black
managers in english football
there's a limited pool of jobs anyway
yep
for me it's the positions below the
managers
you know the coaches the physios
the doctors you've got to say who
has been interviewed for that job
have you interviewed one person have you
interviewed 10 people
have you interviewed whatever we need to
know
because then you can see who's
interviewing who's in for the jobs
what's helped me is you know my
experience playing
being able to you know showcase that in
terms of my level two and whatnot
and then people in the fa seen a bit of
talent and saying all right let's
fast-track this guy in a sense but i do
feel at the back of my mind
if it was out of me or another coach who
maybe white
they would go for him i don't know why
it's not negative thinking or any sense
it's just because i've seen it live in
front of me with other coaches
through their experiences you do all the
right things and you do
you know you you tap dance and you you
sing and and you get
you do everything proper correctly
and you still get held back and you say
yourself well there's other guys going
past me
they might have done the same badges of
me but some of them not finished their
badges and still got jobs
definitely my color has held me back how
strong the fa is
and how strong they come across and the
power they have in football and in
england
in general they're not doing enough
football's results based and
you know there's been maybe a few black
managers in the past that have had maybe
one or two results go
not their way and the media are on them
and whatnot and
you know they're not good enough
maybe they need to take a different
approach their style of football is not
good enough their players they're
bringing in they're not good enough etc
whereas maybe a different manager
different color of skin maybe born in
the country he's now all of a sudden
being allowed to be given time he's
building something
his patience is key and whatnot
which black football manager do you
admire to ghana because i was with him
at fulham i know i was a lot younger
but in terms of the whole club how he
changed it
he built a family and a base and a
culture around the club
do you think
getting that job as is has been
influenced by
the then then owner of fulham muhammad
al-fayed yeah coming mainly from
from egypt um coming from somewhere
where maybe he's not white
maybe he was already open to it open to
seeing a different manager in a
different light so
he went with tagana any other person in
charge then
probably he wouldn't have been given a
chance on the opportunity one of the
black coaches i
really admire is uh chris hewton when he
first started he was like an assistant
coach of tottenham
you know he's done really well under
under really tough
circumstances and back then he's done
promotion with brighton and all that
kind of stuff and
newcastle took newcastle up so you know
someone like chris
for sure do you think there will ever be
a non-white manager of england
i think there will be the fa are now
starting to
be a bit more open and public about the
things that they are doing to help
lower and lesser communities all the way
up to the pro game
but i feel that it's changing ever so
slowly and it's and it's growing
the clubs have to start employing
black managers back coaches so
someone will rise to the top england's
not going to pick a manager who's not
done well for their for their clubs or
whatever not everyone's going to be
successful and why should everyone be
successful from a black community
why you know you've got white managers
who've
have had a fantastic career but they've
won nothing
some have relegated some have done okay
but still got jobs and jobs and jobs so
you can't say
every person black manager has to be
successful of course
you can't have that of course but it has
to work in tandem
for that england job to become a reality
yep
if that happens in the next say the next
day yeah 18 months
and then and they and they are given the
time
the time and the tools and the funding
and the support
to actually be successful not just
working on scraps
not working on say you've sold all your
best players and here you go
you know just get on with it actually
you know
parity have actually the tools to show
who like what i can do
under the same pressure that's key that
happens
i think we're in the next phase three to
five years
i think it could happen for sure but if
the first bit doesn't happen
then it could be 10 years it could be 15
years
last one
would your advice be to a young black
man looking to get into coaching
start as soon as possible you know
if you're playing and you're i don't
know
22 start coaching get onto the courses
and get your badges done and just keep
on being a student of
the game yeah yeah i agree i mean as a
young coach
um you know started my coaching pathway
six years ago the age of 20
and i've got my men's team willing
united conference south but that's
already happened through experiences and
and
like you said notes research um getting
onto my
ideas very very early on um you know you
could start your coaching badges at the
age of 16.
why can't you knowing that you know
people like you
are you know coming through and the
passion that's coming through i can i
can feel it i can i can sense it
um that that makes me so happy as well
hearing your experiences
and and you know shedding the light on
important matters because they are
important and
i'm glad i'm i'm the one sitting next to
you addressing it and talking about it
so
thank you you
[Music]
[Music]